السلام عليكم اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره
الرابعه من الرياض التي نخصصها لتغطيه هذا
العنوان العنوان الابرز لهذا اليوم حيث تم
الاعلان من خلال بيان سعودي صيني ايراني
عن استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
الرياض وطهران في غضون شهرين في التفاصيل
فقد اعلنت كل من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران والصين في بيان ثلاثي مشترك عن
التوصل لاتفاق يضمن استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران واعاده
فتح سفارتيهما خلال مده اقصاها شهرا تضمن
البيان المشترك تاكيدا على احترام سياده
كل من الدولتين وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه اضافه الى تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون
الامني بينهما ومناقشه سبل تعزيز العلاقات
بين الرياض والظهران كما اشاد البيان
الثلاثي بجهود كل من سلطنه عمان والعراق
لاستضافتهما
جولات الحوار التي جرت بين الجانبين خلال
عامين 2021-2022
المتابعه والقراءه في هذا البيان من
الرياضه الدكتور محمد السلمي رئيس المعهد
الدولي للدراسات الايرانيه دكتور محمد
مرحبا بك معي دكتور اولا كيف تقرا ما جاء
في هذا البيان وهل كان في اعلانه وتوقيته
مفاجا
اهلا بك يا استاذ خالد المشاهدين
والمشاهدات لا شك قبل يومين كنت على
العربيه وتحدثنا كتعليق عن تصريحات سمو
وزير الخارجيه في لندن يعني كان في لندن
حول ان السعوديه تمد يدها الحوار مع ايران
وانها عازمه على الحوار في هذا الاتجاه
وتحدثنا الحقيقه خلال الاقراء عن اننا
ربما نرى في القريب العاجل يعني جوله
جديده من الحوار وايضا وتحدثت وايضا عن
يكون هنا قد يكون هناك ايضا تحول من مستوى
الامني الى مستوى الدبلوماسي نحن اليوم في
المرحله ما بين مرحلتين مرحله
الحوار الامني والحوار الدبلوماسي حيث ان
توقيع الاتفاقيه اليوم والبيان المشترك
الذي صدر اليوم يعني من قبل معالي وقعت من
الجانب السعودي معالي مستشار الامن الوطني
الدكتور مساعد العيبان ومن الجانب
الايراني مستشار الامن القومي الايراني
علي شامخاني وهذه المرحله الانتقال بين
الامن والسياسه ولهذا اعتقد ان المرحله
هذه مهمه والمرحله الشهرين القادمين في
غايه الاهميه
انها توضعت الكثير من النقاط على الحروف
وهي مرحله انتقاليه في وجهه نظري لبناء
الثقه اكثر يعني نحن نتحدث عن ان هناك شرخ
كبيرا في الثقه بين الرياض وطهران
واعاده ترميم العلاقات يحتاج الى
الانتقاليه وبناء ثقه مهمه وان تتحول
التصريحات والاتفاقيات الى واقع على الارض
وربما نرى ذلك خلال المرحله القادمه
ابتداء من اليمن وربما ايضا خاصه ان هناك
تطور دولي كبير في هذا الملف لا يجب ان
نفصل هذا الجانب عن التطورات الدوليه لكن
المملكه
اكدت دائما انها عازمه على المسار
الدبلوماسي والسياسي في حل الخلافات وانها
يعني تريد بالفعل التوصل الى تسويه لكافه
الخلافات اذا كان هناك رغبه وجديه من
الجانب الاخر وهي الحقيقه النداءات
السعوديه المتكرره منذ ربما 2017 ونحن
نتحدث عن انه لا اشكاليه في الحوار مع
ايران لكن يجب ان يكون هناك اثبات لحسن
النيه والجديه من الجانب الايراني
ما الذي حدث في الجولات السابقه دكتور
محمد الذي يمكن البناء عليه في قراءتنا
ايضا لهذا البيع
لا شك من معلوماتي الحقيقه البسيطه ربما
لست جزء من هذا الحوار لكنني حسب قراءاتي
وبعض المعلومات التي لدي ان هناك كان هناك
طرح لنقاط اساسيه بعدها الامنيه ثم في
بعدها السياسيه والاعلامي
ومحاوله لوضع كافه الخلافات على الطاوله
وخاصه من الجانب السعودي لديهم نقاط واضحه
وجليه في قضيه الاشكاليه مع ايران وسلوكها
في المنطقه
الميليشيات التدخل في الشان الداخلي
السعودي في قضيه دعم بعض الجماعات
المتطرفه او يعني ملح المساحه لها في في
فضاءات مختلفه فيما يتعلق بالجريمه
المنظمه وغيرها لكنها كان الجانب الايراني
كان ليس لديها الكثير من وجهه نظرينا
المملكه لم تطلق صواريخ على ايران لم
تعتدي على الارض الداخل الايراني لم تدخل
في الشهر الداخلي الايراني وجهه نظري ان
الايرانيون كانوا ربما يعني يركزون على
ابعاد اقل اهميه في بعدها الاعلامي ربما
من هذا الجانب لكنها
المملكه لديها نقاط رئيسيه وضعتها على
الطاوله مع الجانب الايراني الايراني
الايراني الحقيقه يعني اذا كان بالفعل
الان يريد حل هذه الخلافات ونحن نتجه الى
مرحله جديده فانا اعتقد اننا سنصل الى
مرحله افضل بكثير خلال السنوات القادمه لا
اتحدث عن فتره قصيره حتى وان عادت
العلاقات من وجهه نظري نحتاج الى بعض الى
بعض الوقت لحل الخلافات مع ايران والوصول
الى حاله طبيعيه كامله لكننا لا زلنا هذه
الشهر العامين الشهرين القادمين في وجهه
نظري مهمه للغايه تحتاج الى كثير من الجهد
من الجانبين تحتاج الى شفافيه كبيره من
الجانبين
واثبات حسن النيه خاصه من الجانب الايراني
وعند القضيه اليمنيه عندنا التطورات في
العراق وفي سوريا ولبنان وغيرها وقد تبدا
من هذه خاصه على الجبهتين ربما
اللبنانيه
واليمنيه ايضا الحاله الحاله السوريه ليست
في بعيد عن ذلك وهناك حديث كثيره عن قضيه
يعني سوريا الى الحضن العربي فكيف ستكون
الاتفاقيات لهذا الجانب كلها نقاط في غايه
الاهميه
وزير كان قبل يومين فقط او قبل الامس وامس
ايضا امس كان كان في دمشق وبالتالي كلها
ارهاصات مهمه اذا وضعناها في اطار هذه
التطورات ندرك ان هناك
توافقات او خطه لتوافقات قادمه اذا كتب
لها النجاح ونحن نتمنى ذلك ستكون بلا شك
يعني لها
انعكاسها الايجابي على الامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه وايضا خاصه ان ايران الحقيقه
في هذه المرحله بالنسبه لها مهم جدا ان
تصل التوافقات مع الدول الجوار في الماضي
كان هناك حسابات خاطئه من البعد الايراني
حتى في اطار الاتفاق النووي انه اذا
اتفقنا مع القوه الكبرى سوف توافق دول
المنطقه بشكل مباشر على على هذا الاتفاق
اثبت الواقع والتاريخ ان ان هذه الحسابات
خاطئه وبالتالي الان عادت ايران حتى وخاصه
ان هناك ايضا حوار حول اعاده احياء اتفاق
النووي هناك لقاءات في فيينا ان حل
الخلافات الاقليميه هو الخطوه الاولى
للوصول الى توافقات دوليه لكن ربما في
الجانب الاخر الاوروبي وامريكي هناك
اشكاليات اوكرانيا وغيرها لكن المملكه
ليست مشتاقه لهذا الجانب المملكه تريد
الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه تريد ان تصل
الى تفاهمات جديه مع ايران تثبت حسن
النوايا من الجانب الايراني والانتقال الى
مرحله الحقيقه تكون ايران جزء من التنميه
في المنطقه
احنا ما نتكلم عن اتفاق هنا
نتحدث عن مذكره تفاهم لخطوات قادمه ستتم
خلال شهرين تبدا باعاده فتح السفرتين
اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين
في خطوتها الاولى وفي مرحلتها الاولى حتى
نفسر الامر فقط ونفهم
نعم
الان
صدر هو البيان المشترك الثلاثي المشترك
الذي يجوز من ايران من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والصين يدون المستضيفه لهذا
الحوار وبالتالي
تفاصيل الاتفاقيه بشكلها الدقيق ظهرت فقط
خطوط عريضه نتحدث عن عدم التدخل الشؤون
الداخليه للدول نتحدث عن تفعيل اتفاقيه
الامنيه التي وقعت في عام 2001 وكان هناك
اخلال من الجانب الايراني الحقيقه بهذه
الاتفاقيه بعد الان 22 سنه منذ توقيعها
تفعيل واتفاقيه سيتم الان الخلافات
والوصول الى تفاهمات بعد ذلك ننتقل الى
البعد الاقتصادي والتجاري في البدايه اذا
من تفعيل كذلك الاتفاقيه الامنيه بين
البلدين دكتور محمد
بعد بعد عوده فتح الدبلوماسيه سنحتاج ايضا
الى كثير من الوقت
لعوده حلقات طبيعيه مئه بالمئه مع الجانب
الايراني نحن ايران دوله جاره ونحتاج الى
علاقات جيده مع ايران تحتاج المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في كثير من القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه ورات التاثير المملكه
في الدبلوماسيه العالميه ولهذا تريد
الحقيقه
تكسب المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذه
الجانب والا الجانب لا تكل المملكه
الحقيقه يعني
يعني مؤثر سياسي
ودبلوماسي في كثير من القضايا التي تضر
بايرانو لان المملكه تنظر لمصالحها
بالدرجه الاولى ولا يهمها وهذه نقطه لا
يهمها ان تؤثروا على ايران بقدر ما هي ان
تحمي مصالحها
وحدودها وامنها واستقرارها وعدم التدخل في
شانها الداخلي وهو الشعار الذي ترفع
المملكه دائما واحد روابط السياسه
الخارجيه السعوديه التي تتدخل في الشؤون
الداخل الداخليه الدول الاخرى لكنها لن
تسمح لاحد بالتدخل في شانها الداخلي
دعني ارحب ايضا بضيفي الذي ينضم الينا
كذلك من القاهره محمد مجاهد الزيات مستشار
المركز القومي لدراسات الشرق الاوسط دكتور
محمد مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
دكتور يعني ما رايك فيما جاء في هذا
البيان وحتى في البيان الايراني حول
اعاده فتح السفارات والعلاقات بين الرياض
والطهران وبوساطه صيني لماذا الصين ماذا
عن توقيت هذا التغير او هذا التطور الان
وتوقيت هذا القرار
يعني
انا قادر ان هذا تطور لم يكن مفاجئا
بالنسبه لي طبقا لتصريحات كبار المسؤولين
المسؤولين في البلدين وجولات المباحثات
والمفاوضات التي جرت خمس جولات جرت سواء
عبر سلطنه عمان او عبر العراق وكان هناك
توجه من المملكه العربيه السعوديه بالبحث
عن صيغه لتهدئه العلاقات وتخفيض التوتر
النقطه الثانيه هو بيان او موافقه على فتح
السفارتين لكنه لا يتضمن اتفاقه معينه ولم
يؤكد ان خلال الجلسه التي تمت في الصين لم
يطرح على طاوله المفاوضات الملفات التي
فيها اشتباك وفيها اختلاف بين وجهات نظر
البلدين السؤال لماذا الصين انا اعتقد ان
الصين تحاول الابقاء على حد مناسب من
علاقتها مع ايران فبعد القيمه الثلاثه
التي عقدها الزعيم الصيني في الرياض
واتخاذ موقف تتبنى وجهه نظر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من التهديدات الايرانيه
جاءت العلاقات بين ايران وبين الصين وكان
زياره الرئيس الايراني للصين الاخيره
لاستيعاب بالحساسيات التي نشات بهذا
الخصوص ف
دخلت حاولت تقديم شيء ما يربي الايران
ويقرب المسافه في هذا التوتر وفي هذه
العلاقات الثنائيه ما بين المملكه وما بين
ايران فجاءت هذه الموافقه على فتح السفاره
فتح السفاره يعني خطوه مبدئيه او من حيث
المبدا نحن نقدم وجهه نظر
ايجابيه بعد الشهرين سيكون هناك الحديث عن
ملفات اساسيه تمثل درجه مهمه للامن القومي
السعودي وعلى راسها ملف اليمن ما الذي
يمكن ان تقدمه ايران لتخفيف الاحتقان
القائم والتهديد القادم من الحوثيين في
اليمن والتي تحركهم اير
ان بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
بعد ذلك ملفين مهمين مرتبطين به وهو ملف
البرنامج الصاروخي الايراني الذي تعتبره
السعوديه ودول الخليج مهددا للاستقرار ليس
في فيما يتعلق بانها الوطني ولكن بالامن
الاقليمي بصوره عامه وكذلك البرنامج
النووي الايراني ومماثله من تهديد
الملفات الثلاثه هي الاولى اما فيما يتعلق
بالازمات العربيه والانخراط الايراني فيها
فهو ان هناك مجالات في الحديث ومجالات
للتعاون ومجالات الاتخاذ صيغ مشتركه فيما
يتعلق بهذه الازمات واعتقد ان هناك تقدما
المستوى
انت تابعت خلال الفتره الماضيه ان هناك
خمس جولات محادثات عقدت ربما توقفت جوله
سادسه ايضا في هذه المحادثات وكانت هناك
تصريحات بانه الامر جيد ان تعقد محادثات
لكن لم يحصل تقدم كبير وربما هنا استند
الى تصريح وزير الخارجيه السعودي الان هل
سيكون الحوار من اجل الحوار ام ان الصين
ستلعب دور مختلف خلال الفتره القادمه يعني
طبيعه الدور الذي ستقوم به الصين الان
هلال من خلال الفتره القادمه في اي حدود
في اي اطار يمكن النظر اليه
يعني الص
ين الصراع القائم بينها وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والدول الغربيه هناك
لولا الازمه الاوكرانيه لراينا تصعيدا ما
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين
هناك
تحاميركي عسكري مدعوما
من دول الاتجاه الى
التعامل
الى ان تتواجد في خلفيه التمدد الامريكي
الذي يهدد وجودها في اسيا فهي معنيه تماما
بدعم حضورها سواء سياسيا او عسكريا او
اقتصاديا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والخليج
بالدرجه الاولى علاقتها الاستراتيجيه من
خلال اتفاقيات مع ايران تسعى للتسمار
بصوره كبيره ا
يران بدوليا وبالتالي فهي في حاجه الى
الصين والايران الحصار الدولي عليها ارتبط
كذلك وت
زايد مع روسيا
اوكرانيه
الصين تسعى لان تكون قوه يعني تغير هيكل
التوازن الدولي ومن خلال التحالف مع ايران
التحالف المنضبط الذي لا يشير دول الخليج
الكبرى والتي تمثل اهميه كبيره بالنسبه
للصين اعتقد هذا هدف استراتيجي للصين تسعى
الى تحقيقه استاذ محمد السلمي تالا بانه
كان هناك تباينات ورؤى بين البلدين في
مساله معالجه القضايا وحتى في في اليات
ربما الحوار الذي يتم ايران كانت تصر او
ترى بان يتم ذلك
مبدئيا في خطوته الاولى بتبادل القنصليات
بعوده
الدبلوماسيين كخطوه اولى لتحسين العلاقات
وربما هذا ما كنت تشير اليه لانه بان
ايران كانت تريد من هذا الامر ان تحدث
فرقعه اعلاميه يخدمها يعني في هذا الامر
فبالتالي اذا كان الامر بالفعل اليوم بدا
بهذه نقطه ثم يتم الحديث عن بعض الملفات
التي ترى ايران بانها هي ملفات معقده
ملفات شائكه تحتاج لوقت طويل لاجراء
المحادثات هنا هل يمكن الحديث عن
ضمانه صينيه
في هذه النقطه تحديدا هذه هي المرحله
الاولى وبالتالي سيكون هناك دور اكبر
للصين خلال محادثات القادمه في شهرين
القادمه
اتذكر انه في عام 2018 كنا في مؤتمر في في
واشنطن العاصمه ونتحدث عن الوساطه بين
السعوديه وايران والدور الدول بعض الدول
المنطقه من ضمن باكستان انذاك تريد
الوساطه قمت بالحرف الواحد ولا زلت تذكر
ذلك جيدا ان دول الوحيده المؤهله للعب دور
الوساطه بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران هي الصين لماذا الصين اولا الصين
هي الشريك الاقتصادي رقم واحد لايران
وايضا ايران تصدر معظم منتجاتها سواء بشكل
رسمي او عبر التهريب خاصه البعد النفطي
الى الصين وبالتالي العمود الفقري لكل
ربما التماسك خلينا نقول التماسك
الاقتصاديه الايراني هي الصين والصين
لديها مبادره الحزام والطريق وهي معتمده
بشكل اساسي على الامن والاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه وبالتالي الدور الايراني في
المنطقه يؤثر على نجاح سلبيا يمثل سلبيا
على النجاح الحقيقه المبادره الحزام
والطريق ولهذا في كل اللقاءات مع الاخوه
الصينيه يعني الاصدقاء الصينيين نقول انه
يجب ان يكون هناك ضغوطات على الجانب
الايراني لتحقيق يعني صفقه رابحه للجميع
المرحله هذه انت ذكرت نقطه
لها في مداخلته السابقه ايضا قبل قليل انه
هل نبدا بترميم العلاقات ثم بعد ذلك نناقش
القضيات القضايا الكبرى او نبدا بالقضاء
الكبرى ثم نرمم العلاقات الشهران القادمة
لذلك هذا الوسط ربما الوساطه الصينيه لعبه
الدول الاكبر في هذا الجانب يعني هنا اكون
هناك مرحله انتقاليه
الشهران القادمان مهمان للغايه قبل قضيه
فتح يعني فتح البعثات الدبلوماسيه
لابد ان يكون هناك وضع خطوط عريضه لمسار
العلاقه الدبلوماسيه كذلك التفاصيل التي
يعني وردت في
الاتفاقيه التي وقعت بحضور الجانبين
الصيني او البيان المشترك والتفاصيل نتحدث
عن حوار الاستمرار لمده اربع ايام في بكين
والاربعه ايام ليست لصياغه هذا البيان فقط
البيان هو هو ما يخرج الاعلام لكن
التفاصيل الداخليه المهمه ستخرج الكثير ما
تسريبات الموجات نظري خلال اليومين
والثلاثه القادمه عن مزيد من التفاصيل هذا
الاتفاق لكنه من المؤكد ان يكون هناك ضمان
لعدم حقيقه استمراريه التلاعب الايراني في
قضيه الحوار من اجل الحوار التي اشرت
اليها وقضيه بعض رسائل داخليه وخارجيه
اننا نتحاور مع دول الجوار وبالتالي وخاصه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذه النقطه
تحديدا دكتور محمد يعني هل يمكن توقع دور
متقدم للصين عندما يتم البدء بمناقشه
الملفات انت تعرف بان هناك العديد من
الملفات ربما الملف اليمني ملف تدخلات
ايران الى فيلم ليشيات ملف الاسلحه التي
ترسل الى ميليشيات ايران في المنطقه
الكثير من الملفات الشائكه والمعقده يعني
فبالتالي دور الصين هنا التي ستستضيف
سلسله المحادثات القادمه بين الطرفين ما
هو تحديد
هو غالبا هو محاوله الوصول الى حل توافق
بين الجانبين ولكن انه ايضا مهم للصين ان
تراعي مصالحها ومصالحها كما ذكرت هو في
الاستقرار والامن في المنطقه والا يعني في
الماضي كان اشكاليه يعني ايران لعبت في
المنطقه
رماديه مهم تعرف التنافس بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين وبالتالي ايران
لعبت الصين حاولت تدعم ميران بشكل اخر في
كثير من الملفات ليس لاجل الصيني ولكن من
اجل الصراعة من الولايات المتحده ليس من
اجل ايران عفوا ولكن من اجل الصراع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن مصالح
الصين في الوقت الراهن وبعد خاصه بعد
زياره الرئيس الصيني للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والثلاثه القمم التي حصلت
والبيان الصيني الذي تحدث لاول مره عن
الجزر الاماراتيه الثلاث في غايه الاهميه
ان الصين تنظر لمصلحتها اولا ولهذا سيكون
هناك ض
غط نعرف ان الصين تخلت عن قضيه النوع
القوه الناعمه فقط كان ذات الاساسيه
الماضي هو الاقتصاد وهو الناعمه الان تصير
دخلت المرحله الجديده وهي الجيو السياسيه
او الجيوب وهي قضيه ان مسارات مسارات
الاقتصاد تحتاج الى حمايه والحمايه تحتاج
الى تواجد على الارض ويحتاج الى بعد سياسي
وتاثير سياسي بكثير من الدول العالم على
الاقل الدول التي تمر من خلالها طرق
التجاره الصينيه ولهذا وجهه نظري ان الصين
ستمارس الضغوطات على ايران لاجل بحد معين
ليس ضغوطات نتحدث عنه انه اجبار لايران
لكنه ما يضمن مصالح كل الاطراف ولا ان
تكوني ايران هي فقط الرابعه من العلاقه مع
الصين بينما يتم استهداف السفن على سبيل
المثال في مياه الخليج العربي التي بعضها
تنقل الطاقه الى الشرق من بينها الصين
ولهذا المرحله هذه في غايه الاهميه الصين
ستكون جاده في قضيه يعني لعب دور الوسيط
وضمان نجاح المبادره الصينيه وهي يعني ان
الصين تدخل في خط مهم يعني على المستوى
الدولي في قضيه حل الخلافات على مستوى
كبير جدا ربما يعني يعني عجزت عنه كثير من
دول العالم نعرف ان اليابان تدخلت العراق
الباكستان حاولت كثير من الدول العالم
ربي احاول ان تحل الخلاف السعودي الايراني
ولم تنجح نجاح الصين حتى وان كان مبدئيا
سيعزز دور الصين في قضيه ما يسمى بالقنفلت
الخلافات على مستوى العالمي ويعزز مكانتها
السياسيه في كثير من الملفات ليس فقط
الملف السعودي الايراني وهو الاهم من نجحت
الصين في ذلك ونتمنى ان يكون هناك نجاح ما
يخدم مصالح وطننا العزيز فقط هذا الخبر
العاجل خطوات كبيره جدا نجاح كبير في ظل
تراجع غربي اعود اليك بس ابغى اشير اريد
الاشاره هنا الى الخبر العاجل من البيت
الابيض بان واشنطن ترحب باي جهود تساعد في
استئناف العلاقات بين البلدين وهي على علم
بهذه التقارير التي تتحدث عن استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
ربما نفرد مساحه دكتور محمد وضيوفي كذلك
الى الموقف الدولي بدا بموقف البيت الابيض
لكن قبل ذلك دكتور محمد حتى ان نفهم فقط
انه خلال الشهرين القادمين سيكون
العمليه هي عمليه
لوضع اليات العمل الدبلوماسي ام انه ستكون
هناك محادثات تركز على مناقشه الملفات
يعني اذا حصل تقدم سيتم فتح السفاره ام
انه لا خلاص الامر القرار اتخذ وسيتم
اتخاذ الاجراءات الدبلوماسيه الكفيله الان
فقط
تقنيا باعاده فتح السفارتين
انا وجهت نظري انه الاثنان معا اولا سيكون
هناك مجموعات عمل مكثفه بين الجانبين
السعودي والايراني من وجهه نظري بواسطه
صينيه وسيكون هناك تهيئه المكان والسبل
الادوات الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه لحل لاعاده
فتح العلاقات
البعثات الدبلوماسيه البيان تحدث عن عن
اعاده فتح البعثات الدبلوماسيه خلال شهرين
على اقصى حد يعني نتحدث عن فتره زمنيه هذه
الفتره الزمنيه انا وجهه نظري ستستمر في
قضيه انه سيستمرون في قضيه تهيئه يعني
تجهيز المواقع والبعد الدبلوماسي والسياسي
القانوني في هذا الجانب لكنه هناك فرق عمل
ستكون او اجتماعات مكثفه بين الجانبين
السعودي والايراني بواساطه حضور وحظور
صيني
لوضع الكثير من النقاط من التفاصيل التي
لا لم تعلن بعد موجات نظري ولا نعرف عنها
الكثير سيكون يعني هناك عمل كبير نحن
نتحدث ما بعد وجهه نظري هذه الشهرين مهمين
ووضع وقد يكون هناك شيء اكبر من هذا خلال
الشهرين القادمين في قضيه توا اتفاق معلن
تفاصيل كامله على اقل تقدير لكن حتى
لاقامه الحجه في هذا الجانب لكن ما بعد
ذلك ما بعد اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
كيف ستسير الامور نعم وكنا نقول دائما
النيران تريد بناء اعاده العلاقات مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كهدف استراتيجي
حقيقه بالنسبه لها وبين المملكه تريد حل
الخلافات كهدف استراتيجي ثم بعد ذلك اذا
اعاده العلاقات هو علاقات التي لتنميه
العلاقه العلاقه بين الجانبين وليست رمزيه
ما الذي سيحصل بعد شهرين هذا مهم للغايه
دكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه من واشنطن مرحبا بك
دكتور وليد هذا هو الموقف الاول الان من
البيت الابيض وجاء سريعا يعني واشنطن حسب
البيت الابيض على علم بتقارير استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
وكذلك واشنطن كانت على علم بهذه التقارير
التي تتحدث عن الجهود التي تتم في هذا
الاطار لكن الامر غريب دكتور وليد هذا
الامر او هذا التطور يحصل بعد عده تطورات
يعني وجولات مكوكيه تمت خلال فتره الاسبوع
الماضي يعني الجوله او زياره قامت بها
وزير الدفاع الامريكي للمنطقه يتم الحديث
عن سيناريوهات متعدده لمواجهه ايران
لضربات عسكريه ايضا في اسرائيل في العراق
في الاردن قبل ذلك كذلك مسؤول الامن
القومي الامريكي يعني في المنطقه
لهذا الخصوص
الامر ايضا
رافاييل الجلوسي مسؤول الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الداريه كان في طهران
تراجع بعد ذلك النظام الايراني وافق على
عوده مفتشين الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه دون قيد او شرط واليوم بيان سعودي
ايراني صيني يعني يتحدث عن استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
خلال شهرين كل ذلك هل حدث بشكل مترابط
نتحدث عن تنسيق تم بين كل الاطراف ام انه
ما حدث امر مفاجئ ربما يحمي من سيناريوهات
كان يمكن ان تحدث في المنطقه خلال الفتره
القادمه
اذا اردنا تلخيص ما يجري هي لعبه شطرنج
متعدده الجوانب يعني طبعا هي مرتبطه عندما
يتحرك طرف طرف الاخر يتحرك ايضا للحفاظ
على مصالحه فاذا اردنا يعني فهم
النوايا وراء هذا الموضوع تكلمتم اولا عن
الموقف الامريكي موقف الاداره بحد ذاتها
هي لن تمانع تحسين العلاقات بين ايران
والسعوديه
لنتذكر انه اساس الموقف عند اداره بايدن
هو الاتفاق النووي الايراني والاتفاق
النووي الايراني اساسا فيه الصين وروسيا
والدول الغربيه لما هنالك ولكن اداره
بايدن محشوره كما يقال مضغوط عليها داخليا
والان خاصه بعد المظاهرات داخل ايران فهي
سترحب بهذا الموضوع كنت سوف تقول انا لا
علاقه لي فيه هي الصين وايران والسعوديه
ارادوا ان يعني يتقدموا بهذا الاتجاه هذا
الموقف الامريكي الموقف الصيني فعلا
لعلاقه اللي في مدياني على مستوى التحركات
يعني من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
تساؤلكم انه هل الجميع متامرين هل الجميع
يخلقون هذه الحاله بايدن سوف يقول
للكونجرس نحن لا ننسى
يسائله عن هذا الموضوع اين اصبح حديثنا
السعودي اين اصبحت الصين هذا سوف يحصل في
الكونجرس بايدن يقول هم ارادوا ان
يتقاربوا ولكن هو مؤيد لهذا الموضوع عمليا
مؤيد لانه يسهل العوده اتفاق النووي
الايراني الموقف الصيني
السياسه والجيو السياسه قد يكون على الوضع
الاقتصادي يعني لهم حلاقه ممتازه قويه مع
الخليج
تفضلتم بالنشره بالاشاره الى 120 مليار
دولار مع المملكه 80 مليار دولار اذا
الصين اليوم يهمها الاسواق ولها علاقه
ايضا اقتصاديه واكثر من اقتصاديه مع ايران
وهي قلقه من انه اي اشتعال لاي فتيل في
المنطقه سوف يخسرها
في الصين هذا الموضوع وبالتالي من مصلحتها
ان يكون هنالك علاقات يعني على الاقل
طبيعيه غير مواجهه بين المملكه وايران
ايران الموقف الايراني هو انها تشعر كما
تفضلتم بانه في تحركات بين هلالي المريبه
تجاهها لانه هي التزمت مع الرؤوس وتسلح
الروس والروس يصلحونها فهي شعرت بان
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ينظرون الى احتمال اخر تجاه ايران اذا
استمرت في
هذا التوسع اذا هي تحاول ربما ان تميز بين
الخليج من ناحيه وحلفاء امريكا كاسرائيل
وغيرهم من ناحيه اخرى لتخفف الضغط عنها
اذن جميع هذه الاطراف لها مصلحه ان يتم
تبريد الامور بين المملكه وايران بالتالي
هل ستدعم واشنطن فعليا هذا القرار هذه هذا
البيان بشكل فعلي الان ام سيكون لها موقف
لانه اذا ما دخلت الصين بالوساطه بين
ايران وبين كذلك المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في منطقه مهمه للعالم كالخليج فهو كذلك
يعني ان يكون هناك دور اكبر نفوذ اكبر
للصين في هذه المنطقه وهو ما يتعارض ربما
مع السياسه الامريكيه ليس كذلك دكتور
مميز بين
الاثنين لو كانت هي جالسه الى طاوله مربعه
كانت تريد ان تكون هي والصين وايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وربما حلمه
المفاوضون الامريكيون لهذه الاداره انهم
هم الذين يجب ان يكونوا على طاوله ثلاثيه
هم وايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا
غير ممكن الان في الاجواء القائمه في
المنطقه ايران تتوسع وتدخل تقريبا الحرب
الاوكرانيه هنالك ضغط كبير داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على بايدن ان لا يعطي
ايران اي ورقه ما دامت هي تدعم روسيا
الصين دخلت الصين الى المعادله من باب
ارتباط ايران بروسيا فرحب بها جميع
الاطراف لانه جميع الاطراف بما فيه
المملكه هم مع ان تكون هنالك تبريد للامور
وعوده للاستقرار فلعبت الصين ورقه رابحه
جدا على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
ايضا بضيف الذي ينضم الينا من الكويت
الدكتور عايد المناع
الباحث السياسي دكتور
ما رايك في هذا التطور في هذا التوقيت ولو
دخلنا في التفاصيل الان خلاص ستفتح
السفارتين بين او سفرتان بين البلدين في
غضون شهرين لكن المشكله دائما في اي حوار
بين البلدين هي تكمن في التفاصيل وبالتالي
يعني اذا ما قالت ايران او رات اصلا في
الجولات السابقه بان هذه الملفات ملفات
معقده ملفات شائكه يعني ملفات تحتاج وقت
طويل فما هو مصير هذه الملفات ودعنا ناخذ
بدايه مثلا الملف اليمني كيف ستنعكس
سينعكس هذا البيان على على هذا الموضوع
تحديدا على مساله وصول الاسلحه الى الى
ميليشيا الحوثي وهي كانت ايضا مشكله
تواجهها المنطقه خلال فتره الماضيه هل
سيتغير الامر الان
تحياتي لك اخي خالد تحياتي لضيوفك الاكارم
نعم خبر الحقيقه في غايه الاهميه واتى
الحقيقه بعد مفاوضات طويله كان العراق
يستضيفها يمكن ايضا بلدان اخرى اعتقد مثل
الاردن استضافوا محادثات
مخابراتيه ومن ثم دبلوماسيه
للوصول الى ما وصل تم الحديث عنه الان
بالوساطه الصينيه انا اعتقد انه يعني
السعوديين لعب والورقه بشكل احترافي بانهم
لم يذهبوا مهرولين لاي علاقه مع ايران
وانما
حرصوا على ان ياخذوا وقتهم بالتفاوض على
كل الابعاد قدروا الاشقاء والاصدقاء
وتفاوضوا مع الايرانيين اليوم ايران تشعر
الحقيقه بالاختناق بنتيجه الضغوط
الاقتصاديه وايضا حلف عن الحقيقه الذي
تحرص عليهم ايضا مختنقين يعني الحوثي وضعه
الحقيقه ليس على ما يرام لبنان في وضع في
غايه التعاسه ويهم ايران الا يتاثر وضع
لبنان حرصا على حزب الله وليس على لبنان
النظام السوري ايضا هناك حديث عن اعاده
تاهيل في الجامعه العربيه ايران ايضا تلعب
في الساحه السوريه للاسف لاجل من هذا
الجانب وكل ذلك الحقيقه الان ايران في ظل
هذه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الضاغطه عليها لا
تستطيع ان تمد هذه القوه التابعه لها
بامدادات تساعدها على ان تكون لها حضور في
الساحه التي هي فيها وبالتالي جاءت
الوساطه الصينيه
لتنقد الموقف من الجانب الايراني بالنسبه
للسعوديين انا اعتقد انه الاول لم يكن
لديهم يعني رغبه بان يقطعوا العلاقات ولكن
تصرفات ايران السابقه هي التي ادت الى ذلك
تذكر الحقيقه مهاجمه السفاره السعوديه
والقنصليه السعوديه في مشهد وغيره كل هذا
عده الى ما ادى اليه الان اذا ايران
الحقيقه فكرت بعقليه الدوله وليس بعقليه
الفوضى الثوريه المعتاده انا اعتقد ستكون
العلاقات طيبه وستكون لصالح الاقليم لانه
كلنا نريد السلم والامن والاستقرار نحن لم
نطلب اسقاط النظام وليس قضيتنا هذا قضيه
الشعوب اوكي هذا الكلام قديم جديد دكتور
يعني تعودنا عليه ونعرفه لكن تعرف بان
الرياض في في في مساله المحادثات والحوار
مع ايران كانت وما زالت واضحه وصريحه في
اليمن تطلب تعهدات من طهران بوقف الدعم
العسكري والسياسي لجماعه انصار الله
الحوطيه في اليمن
تطلب دائما ان تسهم في الدفع قدما للتوصل
الى حل سياسي للازمه هناك بالاستناد الى
الشرعيه الدوليه الى المبادره الخليجيه
العمل على وقف شامل لاطلاق النار
تمديد الهدنه الذي ترفضه حتى الان يعني
الحوثي في اليمن فبالتالي هل يمكن ان
نتوقع تغيرا تغيرا سريعا دكتور في هذا
الموضوع بالارتباط طبعا مع مساله فتح
السفارات القريه
انا اعتقد انه ايران
العام في ظلها الاوضاع واذا كانت مثل ما
قلت لك فكرت بعقليه الدوله
ستضحي بكل الحلفاء بدون استثناء وهو يبدو
انها تتجه الى ان تهتم بالداخل ولا اقول
تنكفي ولكن تهتم بالداخل الذي ابدا
انزعاجا من اوضاعه الداخليه ليس فقط والله
انه
حجابه وما شابه ذلك اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه
في ايران وبالتالي
هذا الاستنزاف
للاموال الايرانيه والتسليح الايراني لقوى
معينه مثل الحوثي ومثل حزب الله قد ياتي
يوم تقول فيه ايران انه انا شاني الداخلي
اولى من الشان الخارجي وتضحي فيه متى هذا
الحقيقه يحتاج الى بعض الوقت ولكن تاكد
انه اذا اصبحت العلاقات واضحه وطيبه ما
بين السعوديه وما بين
الايران انا اعتقد انه على الحوثي ان يقرر
بانه لم يعد لديه من يسنده لانه لا يمكن
ان تضحي ايران بعلاقات مع دوله كبرى في
الاقليم ومؤثره اقليميا وعالميا من اجل
عصابه متمرده على الشرعيه الدستوريه وخاصه
من السعوديين مستعدين للتفاهم على ايجاد
حل لا يلغي الحوثي من المعادله السياسيه
ولكنه الحقيقه لا يبرر له بان يكون هو
القوه الحاكمه في اليمن دون مرجعيه يمنيه
في هذا الجانب ينضم لنا من بكين صحفي نادر
رنج سيد نادر ماذا عن الصين هنا يعني هذه
القصه قصه الدخول الان في وساطه لاستئناف
العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران في هذا
التوقيت وما هو طبيعه الدور الذي ستقوم به
الصين مستقبله
اهلا ومرحبا بكم طبعا الصين يعني مسروره
جدا
بانجاح هذه
الاتفاق او التدبير العلاقه استئناف
العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران فالسين تريد
ان ترى يعني منطقه شرق الاوسط منطقه
مستجرا وامنا ومنطقه يعني
[موسيقى]
تتوجه الى التقدم
بدلا من الصراعات والمواجهات فلذلك الصين
ايضا ستكون المدافع للوحده في المنطقه
وكذلك
الاستقلاليه في المنطقه ومعرضه
التدخلات القوه الخارجيه في هذه المنطقه
وكذلك السيد لديها ايضا مصالح مشتركه مع
الدول المنطقه
ويجب يعني توسعها وحمايتها
لكن كيف ستضمن الصين بعد ذلك
هذا الاتفاق او هذه المحادثات التي ستجري
بين
البلدين في الملفات المعقده والشائكه التي
كانت سببا في في قطع العلاقات وفي
الخلافات بينهما
طبعا مبدا الصين يعني تجاه
علاقاتها مع دول المنطقه هي السياسات
الخارجيه هو ان الصين تشجع الدول المنطقه
على
حل الخلافات عبر تشاور والتفاوض والحوار
وبطرق سلميه وكذلك يعني
التعاون رغم وجود الخلافات
فلذلك
راينا يعني هناك التقارب والان بين
السعوديه وايران والسين لديها يعني
التعاون كبير مع كلا البلدين
وعلاقاتها الاستراتيجيه شامله بين مع
السعوديه وكذلك مع يعني ايران يعني
لذلك لديها قوه التاثير كبير
لكي يعني تدمن
يعني تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق هو الالتزامك
ايران بها
فلذلك يعني
في اي حدود ستكون لو تعودنا في المنطقه ان
المفاوض الايراني له طريقتان في هذه
المفاوضات طريقه فوق الطاوله وطريقه تحت
الطاوله
تقوم بعمل حوار دبلوماسي لكن مع الاطراف
ولكنها تحت الطاوله تقوم بما يناقض كل ذلك
امداد هذه الميليشيات باسلحه في المناطق
التي تشهد توترات التي تتدخل في شؤون هذه
الدول في المنطقه فبالتالي ما الدور الذي
ستقوم به الصين او حدود التاثير في هذه
الحاله اذا ما استمرت مثل هذه السياسه
الايرانيه سيد نادر
[موسيقى]
تنميه والسلام وبدله من المواجهات فلذلك
كل هذه الشروط او البيئه يمكن ان تدمن
التزام ايران بهذا الاتفاق وعدم تخريب
النتائج التعاونيه اصدقائي بين الصين
وبينها وبين الصين وطول المنطقه
ينضم الينا ايضا للمتابعه الكاتب الصحفي
جاسر الجاسر استاذ جاسر مرحبا بك ما
المتوقع الان خلال شهرين وهي المده
المنصوصه عليها في هذا البيان لاستئناف
العلاقات وفتح السفارتين وكيف تنظر
السعوديه الى دور الصين في هذه الوساطه ما
هي مدى عن مساله استمرار الحاله التي كنا
عليها الحوار من اجل الحوار دون اي تغيير
في السلوكيات او في
المعالجه ومواجهه المشكلات التي كانت سببا
في التاثير على العلاقات بين البلدين
وقطعها
مساء
الخير اولا هذه تعتبر نقله مفاجئه في
طبيعه
الاحداث والحوارات تحدث منذ ثلاث سنوات
لماذا تم لماذا تمت اليوم لكن تغير موقف
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من القضايا
المحوريه
لديها متطلبات محدده وواضحه كانت تطرح في
كل المفاوضات السابقه ولم يكن هناك
تحرك لماذا وافقت اليوم وافقت اليوم او
قبلته وتحقق هذا يعني هذا البيان او هذا
الاتفاق بناء على التصور يعني تبدل مهم في
الموقف الايراني بما يتناغم مع المتطلبات
التزامات كامله بتعديل الموقف يعني
المملكه لم تكن يعني بحاجه الى هذه
العلاقه هناك الطرفين صح مهمه المملكه
تنظر لها من باب استقرار
وحل خلافه ولذلك النصر البيان بشكل عدم
الت
دخل الدول لم يقل بين البلدين في الدول
ولذلك هذه الرساله مهمه ولا الاتفاق تضمن
التزام انه لن يكون هناك تدخل في الدول
بمعنى يعني الى حد ما او في نقاط معينه
ابعاد اليد الايرانيه عن الدول العربيه
شهرين ماذا سيحدث طبعا هناك تقدير في جانب
مهم بالعلاقه بين المملكه والصين علاقه
يعني حيويه واستراتيجيه العلاقه بين
الرئيس الصيني والامير محمد بن سلمان
بهذه الوساطه اعتقد انها شكلت ما يشبه
الضمان لالتزامات ايران بالتعهدات التي تم
عليها الاتفاق خلال المفاوضات ولو خلت في
مثل هذه الاتفاقات فهي ستخسر الصين كليا
لن تكون الصين يعني
التقدير والثقه اول خطوه نتوقع انها ترك
خلال هذه شهرين التبدل في المشهد اليمني
ايران اليوم هذا التبدل الذي ترى
يعني مثل ما قالت دكتور ايضا احنا المملكه
من 2016 وهي تقول الحوثي مكون ايراني عفوا
مكون يمني لا نستبعده لكن يريد ان نريد ان
يكون مكون يمني فعلي وليس ذراعا اذا اليوم
ايران لا تستطيع ان تدعم الحوثي الطرق
كلها مغلقه وشاهدنا عمليات مصادرات
الاسلحه بالفترات الاخيره يعني خلال
فتره واضحين خلال فتره كانت المفاوضات
تجري في بغداد ايضا كانت ايران ترسل اسلحه
اللحود
الفتره الاخيره كانت زادت عمليات المصادره
لهذه الاسلحه اذا ايران اليوم في هي في
جانب وضع صعب لا تستطيع اقتصاديا تواجه
مشاكل داخليه لحصر لها تواجه تهديد خارجي
كله حلفائها في الدول العربيه تواجهون
مشاكل هناك تبديلات العوده الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه عوده للاستقرار اذا
استمر فنحن هنا
نراه دوله وليس موقف النظام هل تستطيع
الدوله ان تلتزم بها بشكل هل هي حاله خروج
من الاختناق انا اعتقد انه لا اشكاليه
يعني نتمنى انه تحقق هذا المسائل
او لم تنفذ ايران المتطلبات الاساسيه او
لم تبرهن على جديه هذا الاتفاق والتزامها
به من خلال
الحركه في الابتعاد عن المشهد اليمني
والتحرك الايجابي في اليمن وعوده الحوار
بين الاطراف اليمنيه والتشكيل الدوله بشكل
كامل
فالحرب بين هذه الاطراف اذا نحن نتكلم عن
الاتفاقات نظريه فنحن
رهان على الزمن المملكه قدمت الخطوات
كامله فتحت الباب الفكره هذه رساله
بلا اشكاليه لدينا نحن نرحب اذا كنتم
جديون فنحن جديون اذا تلتزمون فنحن نمضي
معكم الاخير اذا لم يكن هناك
المملكه في موقف واضح ومحدد وصريح وبين
اذا البدايه بالملف اليمني
وماذا لو استمرت ايران في السلوك يعني
استخدمت جماعتها المسلحه في ارسال رسائلها
المعتاده يعني في وقت المفاوضات رسائل
التصعيد الضغط رفع حاله التعذيب
مثل هذه الممارسات اذا لم تستطع ان تكون
جاده يعني هل نطرح التساؤل
ماذا ايران قليلا ماذا لو خف عليها الضغط
قليلا ماذا لو استعاده يعني جزء من
القدراتها الماليه ماذا لو خفت على
التجديد
هل ستبقى على هذا
المسار وقدره هذه الدوله ان تكون فعلا
دوله ح وعامل استقرار نجحت المملكه الان
في اعطاء ايران الفرصه الكامله لاغلاق
ملفات التوتر في المنطقه
يعني التهديدات اللي تواجهها رامي اليوم
لا تجعل لها خيارات ولذلك هذا التقلب
ويمكن كانت ايران تقدم هذه التعهدات بشكل
ما سابقا لكن التحول في لنقل الضمان نفسه
الضمان الصيني هنا ما هو
في وجهه نظر السعودي
في تنفيذ ما تم الات
فاق عليه وانه ان لم يتم هذا التنفيذ فان
سيكون هناك اجراءات بمعنى انه ايران ستخسر
بكين تغسل الصين كليا لن تقبل يعني لن
تقبل للصين ان تكون ورقها مشيه تكون
مخدوعه
فجاء الجانب من هذا الجانبين
في وقت الدكتور لانه الوقت اليوم حساس انت
تعرف
وسياسه ايران معروفه في مفاوضاتها في
حوارها دائما يعني ما تستفيد من الوقت
واطاله الى اكثر الى اطول وقت ممكن اطول
امد وهذا الامر خطير ايضا على مستقبل
المنطقه يعني لما نتحدث عن دور الميليشيات
في اليمن في الخليج في العراق في في لبنان
في في سوريا كل هذه المناطق يعني اصبحت
ايران متوغله فيها بشكل
يعني كان له مخاطر كبيره على كل دول
المنطقه يعني وعلى مستقبلها وعلى امنها
القومي
القدره الايرانيه على الوصول لحيثي او
تغيير المشهد لم يعد الحوثي ورقه رابحه
تلعب فيها ايران اصبح تعبت
اذا اخذنا الموقف بحالهم ايضا المملكه
تحدث تسهم في مساعده العراق على الخروج من
ازمته وهذا تحول مهم جدا والتنميه
الاقتصاديه في العراق
نحن نتحدث ايران استنفذت لنقل كل الفرص
التي كانت ممكنه انها تحدث يعني لم تعد
يعني اذا كان الحوثي في عام 20
الورقه قويه في المفاوضات اليوم هو ورقه
خاسره
اذا كانت تراهن في تلك الفتره على انها
تستخدم الحوت او تحاول ان تضغط او
تحصل يعني هل مشكلته
لا اعتقد ان النظام
بين يوم وليله الى
دوله بالمعنى الكامل
اليوم هذا المتنفس لها ولذلك يمكن انها
تريد ترتيب اوراقها
يعني
بالسعودي لا خساره لن يكون الوضع اسوء
مكان
في شيء ممتاز خليني اخذ وجهه نظر الدكتور
عايد الان في المحادثات باي سقف ستدخل
ايران المفاوضات ستدخل من سقف عالي بالنظر
الى تواجدها توهلها في هذه
المناطق في اليمن في العراق في في في
سوريا في في لبنان مع ميليشياتها الموجوده
هناك ولا انه وضعها اليوم تعيش داخليا
والضغط الدولي عليها الذي نشاهده من خلال
يعني اكثر من طرف سيجعلها تتنازل دكتور
خلينا نكون واقعيين بالنظر ايضا الى ايران
وسلوكها ونظامها في المنطقه يعني
اولا الحقيقه نتفق مع اخي جاسر جاسر في
كثير من مقال حقيقه ولا استبعد انه ايران
تستخدم التكتيك
لتحسين اوضاعها الداخليه ومن تبنى بصفته
دوله هيدولوجيه وهذه المشكله مع الدول
الهيدروجيه انها ممكن بما بعد تعود الى
سابق عهده لكن هي الان في مرحله انها تبحث
عن انقاذ وبالتالي هذا هو فرصه انه تعطى
هذه الفرصه المناسبه
لعل وعسى انه عندما تشعر من زمان واحنا
نقول لعل ولا عسى دكتور عايد يعني انت
تعلم يعني بهذا الامر وغيره تستمر في
سياساتها بلخبطه الاوراق او الخلط فيها
والمناوره الدائمه يعني فهي ورقه ربما
تلعبها هذا ما يقوله البعض يعني هي خالد
هي استخدمت هذه الميليشيات
وجودها وقدرتها اذا هذه الامور اصبحت
عليها عبء الى متى الوضع في الداخل هو
الذي يحدد مسار السياسه الخارجيه عندما
تشعر السلطه في ايران ان الناس تعيش حاله
غليان وممكن ان ينفجر الموقف ويتكرر ما
حدث سنه 1979 للساعه في هذا العهد تاكد
انه الحكم او النظام
سيحاول قدر الامكان ان يلعب الورقه
التكتيكيه لكن هنا المطلوب من الصين هو ان
تتقدم بالمطالب نيابه عن مثلا السعوديه
ودول اخرى في الاقليم
بمطالب واضحه وصريحه ان ايران بعد اللقاء
بعد التبادل الدبلوماس وعوده الامور
الطبيعيه لا تكون ايران كما كانت في القبل
انا متاكد ان الحوثي وحزب الله سيص
وهذا قد يكون واقعي لانه حقيقه ايران
شبعتهم من التسليح موجود لديهم وقد ياخذ
هذا بعض الوقت ولكن علاقه طيبه مع ايران
ستسحب البساط من تحت كلها يبقى على ايران
ان تفكر انه ايهما الاولويه مصالحها ام
مصالح
والاخرى يبقي الصين الصين يهمها هو امن
طريق الحرير الى المنطقه وقد الحقيقه
تجامل ايران كثيرا في هذا الجانب ولكن
ينبغي ان تصلها الرساله واضحه اي اخلال
بالاتفاق سيعيد الامور الى ما هو حاليا
ولابد يكون في وقت زمني محدد دكتور يعني
انت اليوم ما تستطيع في دول تفرض عليها
شروط ولكن توصلها مطالبك اذا احترمت هذه
المطالب ووافقت عليها وسارت على الطريقه
الصحيح اليوم نجد هذه يعني حتى الامريكان
فرحانين
لانهم يريد العوده الى الاتفاق خليني اخذ
وجهه نظر الدكتور محمد مجاهد الزيات ايضا
دكتور حاول موقف الجماعات المسلحه
المدعومه من ايران الحوثي
الميليشيات الموجوده في العراق حزب الله
في لبنان يبدو انه فقدنا الاتصال طيب
الدكتور محمد ما رايك الان تعلم بانه في
مثل مثل هذه المواقف عندما تظهر يعني نبره
ايجابيه في محادثات تتم بين الجانبين
الايراني
والسعودي تظهر اصوات اخرى يعني
ترفع الصوت ربما بشكل يؤدي الى عرقلات هذه
المحادثات تصعيد خطابي ضد السعوديه
وشاهدناه في مواقف
سابقه اليوم الموضوع مختلف ام انه هذه
الجماعات ايضا من مصلحتها ان تعرقل اي
محادثات او اي نجاح في اي مفاوضات تتم بين
الرياض والظهره
اولا نركز على نقطه مهمه ان من ثوابت
النظام الايراني هو تدخلات في الشونه
الداخليه للدول الاخرى
والدستور الايراني ينص صراحه على ذلك
وبالتالي ان نقول ان ايران ستتوقف كليا عن
التدخل والاعتماد على الميليشيات بالشكل
او باخر فهو تفكير رغبوي ما لم يكون هناك
ادوات تجبر ايران على الانكفاء الى الداخل
هذه هذه من وجهه نظري قناعه تامه لا اجد
ما يعارضها ما لم يكن هناك حقيقه فعلا
ضغوطات حقيقيه على ايران تجبرها على
العوده الى الداخل النقطه الثانيه
الميليشيات في الخارج الان التي تحدث عنها
انها قد تصدر بعض التصريحات او انها تحاول
ان تعرقل مثل هذه الاتفاقيات انا قد انظر
لها من زاويه اخرى ما هي المساحه التي
ستقدمها ايران او ما هي الاشارات التي
ستبعثها ايران لهذه
الجماعات والميليشيات خلال هذه المرحله
نتمنى ايران دائما اذا كان هناك ضغوطات
على الميليشيات او على قفاضات في الداخل
وتحاول ان تبعث برسائل الخارج اننا لازمنا
اقوياء ولا زلنا داعمون نتذكر عندما اسقطت
ايران الطائره الاوكرانيه في يعني في 2020
بدايه 2020
وضعت خرج حجز وهو قائد القوه الجوف فضائيه
الايرانيه وضع اعلام جميع الدول
الميليشيات الايرانيه في المنطقه في
الخلفيه الى جانب الحرس الثوري وعالم
ايران وبالتالي هي رساله داعمه النقطه
الثالثه اننا
يعني ربما من غير المتوقع ان تعود
العلاقات السعوديه
الكامل طيب انا بكتفي معك بهذا القدر
دكتور محمد واعتذر منك
الوقت تماما شكرا جزيلا لك محمد السلمي
جاسر الجاسر ضيفي من الكويت دكتور عايد
المنه
التغطيه مستمر الدكتور طالب كنعان يصحبكم
على راسي الساعه